[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' à tanis
d'interdire pour cette dernière émission
de la saison je reçois par skype le
philosophe bernard stiegler pour un
livre collectif bifurquer qui vient de
paraître aux liens qui libèrent et je
recevrai ensuite rodolphe burget pour
son nouvel album environ mais on
commence tout de suite pas bernard
stiegler bonjour bernard dans
l'avertissement de bifurquer vous dites
que la pandémie due qu'aux vide 19
prouve que notre modèle économique est
condamné à mort pourquoi bien sûr que je
t'indique a été écrit avant on là qu'on
dénie un ouvrage collectif avec beaucoup
de contributeurs 26 signataires 52 ou 50
points un contributeur très très
transdisciplinaires on va des
mathématiques au droit en passant même
par la littérature les arts etc
l'informatique la biologie kits sont
deux disciplines
évidemment les communes y est ce que
nous soutenons c'est a travaillé quatre
ans il ya deux ans c'est que le modèle
industriel d'économie industrielle qui
règne depuis le siècle presque ont plus
que le siècle est basé sur une physique
newtonienne on me dira sommairement
design physique déterministe et qui ne
tenait absolument pas la question de la
thermodynamique est apparu dans sa
formulation véritablement scientifique
avec goldsman à la fin du 19e siècle le
mot entropie et qui ont été formulées en
en allemagne sap et klaus jeu pour vous
donner un exemple si on devait certifier
les avions en intégrant la tête d'un mot
dynamique et ne volerait pas parce que
ils sont des structures de ma propre
condition de possibilité à moyen à moyen
terme je n'ai pas long terme et à moyen
terme donc un organe de certification
aucun avion de convoler sans être
certifié en venant d'ailleurs qui est un
organe de certification qui prendrait en
compte la théorie thermodynamique ne
laisserai pas les avions volaient et
c'est vrai pour énormément de choses
alors je dis pas d'ailleurs que du coup
il faudrait pas laisser mobilisation
parce qu'elle a toujours des régimes
d'exception
les systèmes immunitaires par exemple
peuvent développer des champs biologique
des fonctionnements intrus atypique par
rapport à la norme
voilà donc ce que je peux nous voulons
dire c'est pas qu'il faut empêcher les
avions gonesse il faut savoir calculer
autrement et en particulier calculée sur
le fait qu'il ya des choses qui sont
incalculables
par exemple le comique 19 c'est pas
qu'elle s'est pas quelque chose de
calculé
donc si on applique les modèles vraiment
des big data d'une manière dogmatique
comme malheureusement c'est le cas
aujourd'hui très très massivement et
dans pratiquement tous les domaines à la
gestion de la sphère sociale de ce qu'on
appelle la santé de la sphère sociale et
bien on ne peut que générer ou augmenter
plutôt ce qu'on appelle l'épidémie
d'épidémie puisque depuis j'ai découvert
ça tout à sa manière une semaine à
travers article d'un biologiste qui
expliquait qu' il y a des gens qui
montrent qu' il ya une épidémie
d'épidémie depuis 1945 et que cette
accélération de l'épidémie est liée à
une accélération du développement
technologique et à la perturbation de
plus en plus des responsables des grands
équilibres disons du matic tellurique
vivant évidemment que fuir cité externe
voilà alors nous étions en train
d'écrire ce livre pour nous avions fini
de l'écrire nous l'avons présenté ce
livre en fête ou dépend encore us ou
presse mais le manuscrit était terminée
le 10 janvier dernier à genève et
surtout à l'adresse des nations unies
puisque ce livre s'adresse directement
au secrétaire général des nations-unies
haut débit du lit il ya une aide de jean
marie le clézio qui explique pourquoi il
s'est associé à notre démarche
1 puis à la lettre anthony roux ténès et
puis ensuite nos développements et
ensuite il ya une postface alain supiot
juristes
nous essayons d'expliquer que nous
pensons maintenant que cohabitent 19
c'est un passage à l'échelle un seuil
c'est insolite est franchie en terme de
gravité et nous ne sommes pas les seuls
à le penser
les électeurs de bordeaux de lyon de
marseille de strasbourg le pensent aussi
en te prie pas une bonne partie d'entre
eux est en fait à peu près le monde
entier y compris en chine
donc voila nous pensons que nous sommes
à 32 d'entrer dans une période qui
pourrait devenir très chaotique
c'est un chiffre comme on dit et 1,6
point positif ou négatif donc nous
essayons nous proposer une manière de
s'y jeter de bifurquer disons de manière
délibérée réfléchi et avec une méthode
c'est une méthode d'expérimentation que
nous appelons les territoires nab
oratoire basés sur des modèles
commencent à se forger avec des
scientifiques ce que nous appelons la
recherche contributives on reviendra sur
la bifurcation que vous souhaitez
bernard stiegler mais reste war un
instant sur le qui-vive 19 depuis là la
grande pandémie de peste au moyen-âge
il ya eu effectivement d'autres
pandémies au fil des siècles mais ça
paraît toujours risqué de les faire
parler parce qu'un virus ne parle pas
pas plus que vides 19 que le sida ou la
peste et à chaque fois on essaye de les
faire parler on veut les faire parler
la peste c'était une punition divine le
sida sté pour punir les homosexuels de
leur débauche de vouloir donner aucun
vide 19 une signification écologique
anti modèle économique telle qu'on le
telle qu'on la pratique et jusqu'à
présent et on y reviendra bien entendu
est-ce que ça n'est pas risqué est ce
que ça n'est pas faire parler à virus
qui par définition ne nous dit rien
alors ce que ce soit risqué c'est
absolument évident tu es contre la
parole pour donner un style dans tous
les cas qui que l'on soit même einstein
des bêtises par exemple pendant huit ans
il a prétendu que ce que vous faites
edwin hubble était puis la fille de 8
ans par dire non tout le monde aurait
bien des buts
y'a pas que donald trump après je
couvert ce risque de voir mais en même
temps c'est un risque qui doit être
calculée et mesurée dire que nous nous
parlons ne sont pas simplement parler le
virus ou travaillant et des virologues
alors maintenant vous avez tout à fait
raison je posais cette question donc
pour un motif bien précis qui à mon avis
d'ailleurs en tout cas pour moi c'est ce
qui me frappe le plus ce qui m'a le plus
frappé dans un contexte de ce qu'on
appelle de la pandémie actuelle c'est de
voir de grands scientifiques des
médecins est vraiment des gens tout à
fait renommée accrédités qui savent très
bien où ils parlent certains je les
connais personnellement et je sais que
sans doute avons-nous extrêmement
sérieux tenir des positions absolument
opposés les uns comme les autres avec
une certitude absolue d'avoir raison
c'est quelque chose que je trouve
extraordinaire pour françois toussaint
par exemple que je peux mais que j'ai
invité au centre pompidou avec j'ai
beaucoup discuté affirme avec une
certitude absolument incroyable qu'il ne
savait pas qui est à l' inverse vous
avez des gens qui affirment avec une
certitude tout aussi incroyable pour moi
qu'il fallait absolument en fils nous
nous disons on
ce tirage on le saura jamais parce que
ça fait partie des trois suspects
indéterminée où il ya une incertitude
immense et avec laquelle il faut compter
alors comment est-ce qu'on compte avec
l'incertitude à céret problème de
problèmes jusque aristote ap la prudence
grâce aux france une immense honte que
aujourd'hui la question n'est plus dieu
comme à l'époque de la peste
la question fondamentale main alors sur
le sida pense qu'il ya d'autres
dimensions enfin plainte a pas été
autrement que comme vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure à propos par exemple la
punition de la débauche
les homosexuels ce que j'ai il ya de
tout de tout autre discours
mais on va laisser des trous petit et ça
se bâtit un point très important je vous
ai dit il de leur que nous préconisons
une employée de méthodes de recherche
intitulé premier avoir fait sens et act
up c'est les gens qui ne travaillent sur
mielleuse il a en france avec des
associations de gens qui était malade et
c'est un complètement bouleversé les
pratiques de recherche médicale c'est
extrêmement importante
je travaille aussi avec un diabétique
face j'ai travaillé avec un diabétique à
un moment donné aujourd'hui des
communautés de diabétiques et en sache
très long sur le diabète qui deviennent
quasiment d'été avec la et georges
canguilhem en outre m si en biologie et
en médecine il était médecin disait le
seul qui sache de quoi il parle en
matière de maladie c'est le banal jeu
c'est angèle parenthèse et je reviens à
la question fondamentale d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la question du risque
pardon quand je dis du risque je veux
dire de l'interprétation
l'interprétation du fcd puis à travers
dieu année plus à travers ce qu'on va
appeler une question sociétale par
exemple le droit ou le pas droit d'avoir
une vie homosexuelle la légitimité de
nos sexualités chose quand même se
souvenir qu alan turing dont on prie
beaucoup ici s'est suicidé parce qu'ils
étaient condamnés en 1953 pour
homosexualité est quand même
extraordinaire quand on y réfléchit
c'est moyen âge pour pour nous il s'est
suicidé parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
supporter l'obligation qui lui était
faite de ceux castrer chimiquement et en
disque
nous disons c'est plus vieux sané plus
les problèmes sociétaux ou moraux de ce
type là c'est la morale l'archaïque
qu'ils soient là c'est l'entropie une
entropie c'est pas simplement dans la
théologie
même si ça démonte et immensément
théologique ça n'est pas simplement une
affaire de morale c'est pour si cela dit
une affaire n'aura jamais parlé dans un
panier qui s'appelle qu'appelle-t-on
penser une décidé de l'entrée il
frédéric nietzsche a fait une dépression
nerveuse à poser j'ai soutenu par
ailleurs je pense que le fait de très
bonnes raisons de le dire mais
l'entreprise c'est une donnée qui je le
rappelle a été comment dire est encore
nier aujourd'hui faisant par ce qu'on
appelle les entre les ex trop bien à qui
prétendent que l'homme pourrait échapper
à l'entropie mais l'entropie site une
donnée qui est un changement absolument
fondamental dans toute vision
cosmologique
parce que jusque en 1865 en prison parce
que les grands débats sur qu'on a appelé
la mort permis de l'univers ce 1858 que
ça peut être très simple jusque là on
considérait que l'univers était
absolument identique est égal à lui-même
et l'éternel et le l'apparition du thème
de l'entreprise et de la mort thermique
de l'univers maintenant on est content
d'être là puis comme ça mais maintenant
ça se combine avec que son physique et
le big bang toutes ces questions la
nouvelle très très drôle question de
physique
c'est un changement absolument radicales
avec toute l'histoire non seulement de
l'occident et de la chine et de toutes
les cautionner et donc je pense que 100
150 ans après seul en mer elles 150 ans
un débat sur la mort d'amy lumière on
n'a toujours pas assimilé et la houle a
le moins a su laisser dans le champ de
l'économie
mais l'entreprise est une réalité et
donc si nous ne la semis n'ont pas
l'entreprise ne s'arrête pas pour autant
que ces versets et du coup nous avons
des tas de problèmes que nous disons ça
on n'est vraiment pas les seuls à le
dire je crois que c'est la très grande
majorité en fait des infectiologues et
épidémiologistes
des virologues et c'est là que
l'accélération des ans des épidémies
noah est ensuite surtout depuis 1990
elles puisqu'il ya eu des apparitions
venue d'un nouveau type en amazigh à ce
moment là il ya une accélération très
spectaculaire très visible à observer
sur des courbes c'est très documenté
aujourd'hui tout cela est que c'est
directement lié rocheman aux changements
de la mode des modes de vie liées à la
globalisation
par exemple moi je ne suis un petit peu
penché comme beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs
à partir du mois de mars sur l'histoire
de la grippe espagnole
la grippe espagnole elle commence en
1916 se poursuit par 1920 peut-être
au-delà mais on est grands événements
c'est du sport 1920 et donc elle
mettrait très longtemps avant de livrer
jusqu'en europe
et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils migrent en
plus c'est parce que l'armée américaine
lignac elle s'engage dans le conflit
européenne est il donc c'est lié à des
vecteurs technique des moyens de
transport des bateaux des avions ennemis
nous vivons cela non plus simplement à
l'échelle des petits bataillon à petit
ils ont des épaules américains qui
viennent s'engager dans la première
population très limité nous vivons à
l'échelle une population mondiale qui
est interconnecté par toutes sortes de
voir les avions pour se transporter mais
aussi des produits qui circulent et c
est évidemment par ailleurs des
déforestations de transformation de
l'habitat d'animaux et d'animaux
sauvages et donc qu'ils sont des hôtes
de virus et donc une transformation
totale des risques biologiques
ça c'est absolument identifier de
manière objective et à martigues leur
notre vous écrivez dans dans ce livre
que d'autres modèles de développement
s'est transformée en guerre civile
mondiale
si c'est le cas comment peut-on l'art
était le seul moyen d'arrêter de guerre
civile c'est de se rendre c'est d'agiter
le drapeau blanc c'est de se constituer
prisonnier
est ce que ce serait sam bifurquait
c'est se rendre alors je dis pas
exactement une guerre civile mondiale
jeudi une guerre commerciale
il ya eu terme qu'à civile mondiale
aussi signé neige
oui parce que ça engendre et c'est la
guerre économique mondiale qui engendre
du coût des conflits entre v et bill et
qui finit par rejoindre est à
l'intérieur même des pays des situations
pas forcément de guerre civile mais un
peu capi qui semble pouvoir mener à la
guerre civile par les gilet jaune ça
c'est pas du tout pour contre dame et
les gels moi je suis plutôt en grande
sympathie avec que même s'ils se veut
pas dire joueurs coin sont extrêmement
diversifié donc les jeunes n'ont pas de
doctrine
par contre c'est un mouvement social qui
est très révolutionnaire certainement ce
que je sois une guerre économique une
guerre civile
le seul moyen d'arrêter une guerre c'est
de se rendre il n'y a pas moyen sinon on
est resté une guerre c'est de la gagner
et moi je suis anglais je suis en guerre
contre la guerre économique c'est à dire
que ce pourquoi nous nous battons en
écrivant puis sur pc où trouver des
accords de paix d'obliger nos
adversaires a signé des accords de paix
est donc ce pays nous posons et ça j'y
crois beaucoup en plus de plus en plus
nous posons que ce que ce que
j'exposerai tout à l'heure très
sommairement qui est développée de
manière très détaillée dans le livre sûr
que c'est très détaillé et c'est fait
par des gens qui sont vraiment
extrêmement compétents dans leur domaine
c'est pas moi qui écrit ce livre c'est
ce collectif que des gens qui savent
très bien quoi il parle
ce que nous disons c'est que le modèle
actuel n'est pas soutenable et que même
même les spéculateurs des marchés
financiers bien un bon quand on sait à
soulever la question parce que parce que
leurs enfants d'avoir son retrait me
lasser et une même meuble est vous
souvenez certainement qu'en 2009 2010 à
13h à la bbc avait déclaré oui je sais
que je sorte on espérait mieux mais je
m'en fous parce que tant qu'il ya du
pognon à faire genre faire était
vraiment fait le tour du monde sur cette
déclaration
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya de moins
en moins de gens qui osent dire ça c'est
pas pour des raisons morales c'est parce
qu'ils se demandent est-ce que ça peut
continuer longtemps comme ça est ce que
moi même je vais pas me retrouver des
nas et tout le monde peut attraper
attraper le petit 19 ça va peut être
coûter très cher à donald trump est
alors je pense que aujourd'hui dans le
monde économique manque financier le
monde industriel notamment que je
pratique un peu et puis je discute
parfois il y a des gens qui sont
conscience
vous savez quand on dirait une grosse
boutique industriels banques elles en
interne est un peu rationnelle sinon m
pas longtemps en place et cette
rationalité il commence sa rationalité
de ces gens là comment savoir très
précisément l'irrationalité du système
dans lequel il se trouve donc je pense
que ces gens sont des seigneurs de la
guerre économique bien on peut les
amener à faire ce qui s'est passé un
moment donné aux japonais quand on a
inventé la cérémonie du thé je vous dis
cela pour moi parce que les gens qui
sont à l'origine de ce qu'on appelle le
bouddhisme zen japonais pour aimanter le
jardin de pierre la série c'était des
symboles des seigneurs de la guerre qui
aiment leur donner ce sont ben il ne
peut pas continuer et qui finalement a
inventé une pacification par la
méditation à la réflexion je vous dis ça
parce que je n'ai parlé beaucoup avec un
japonais que ça peut être chic avec des
tas car j'ai beaucoup travaillé que fait
l'ancien vice-président l'universel todd
hays de tokyo qui est la plus grande
université du japon et qui est un
spécialiste de ces questions et un
article paru d'ailleurs sur ce plan je
vous rappelle aussi que jean-marie
andreck est un historien de la rome
antique a expliqué que les romains
pendant la période augustinienne ont
inventé ce qu'ils ont appelé l'otium
l'otium c'est l'origine c'est ce que les
nec capella scolaire c'est-à-dire la la
paix de l'esprit qui permet de se mettre
à penser à élaborer des nouveaux modèles
et nous sommes dans une période comme ça
nous sommes dans une période où il ya eu
des guerres économiques terribles qui
ont commis des crimes terribles qui ont
pollué d'aylmer entière détruit des
dizaines de millions de filles
alors on dit miliana lutter contre la
pauvreté huit chiffres absolus quand
vous calculez le nombre de gens qui
crèvent de faim on n'a jamais eu autant
de gens sur terre parce qu'autrefois
sûreté avait au début du 20e siècle et
moins d'un milliard d'habitants
donc on a augmenté les problèmes un
nouveau est nord est dans une guerre
économique est devenue totalement
irrationnelle et qui va finir par nous
détruire tous et la génération john
beyrle génération de berne
moi j'ai créé l'association ars
industrialis il y a quinze ans elle a
changé de nom il s'appelle maintenant
l'association des amis de la génération
kannberg les jeunes générations
on se retrouve plus du tout lorsque ont
leurs règles et il faut de toute urgence
avec eux avec ces générations travailler
à mettre en place de nouvelles
perspectives et pas pour faire la
révolution mais pour d'abord je faire
face à l'urgence à l'état d'urgence que
déclare elle donc le secrétaire général
des nations unies antonio guterres est
ce le 10 septembre 2019 2018 par dont il
avait fait un grand discours devant les
296 états membres des nations unies
on n'a eu aucun effet ensuite il a
rassuré le même discours quant à tolbiac
étaient présentes au forum instruments
industrielle au forum économique mondial
de davos d'été le 24 janvier 2010 9,2
dans des dizaines et des dizaines de
très nombreux pagny banques etc
ça n'a eu aucun effet et nous nous bien
l'on écrit pour dire ça n'a aucun effet
parce qu'en fait vous ne prenez pas le
problème cominois que le problème qui
doit être posée c'est que le social la
société industrielle que nous
connaissons tous aujourd'hui où nous
serions dans le monde du contre et au
coeur de l'afrique parce que les
bouteilles de coca arrive au coeur de
l'afrique
ça c'est la société industrielle c'est
la globalisation et bien c'est une une
société qui s'est développée sur un
modèle scientifique qui en fait
aujourd'hui ne permet plus de décrire le
monde tel qu'il est ça permettrait bien
décrire nouvelles ou tonnerre ça
permettrait bien décrire disons les
activités des planètes
action et l'inertie essentiellement il
ya des couches que newton n'avait pas pu
penser c'était trop tôt et qui concerne
les normes aimant les êtres vivants et
donc dans le système solaire il ya une
planète sur laquelle il ya des êtres
vivants nous sommes et ses êtres vivants
qu'est-ce qu'ils font 20 essentiellement
ça c'est ce qu'a montrèrent venture
dinger très gros fini siens nous luttons
contre l'entropie alors les papillons ou
les virus lutte contre l'entreprise de
manière très différente des hommes parce
que les hommes eux ont des organes
artificiels par exemple skype la
télévision des trucs comme ça qui sont
des organes qui peuvent aussi augmenter
l'entropie c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent
aggraver le désordre et réduire le temps
d'espérance de vie
le temps de la vie sur terre ça c'est ce
que vous voyez aujourd'hui 10 pbs par
exemple 1,25 à biodiversité s'est
réduite à un niveau extrêmement
important d'un siècle et qu'elle
s'accélère cette réduction biodiversité
or nous savons très bien que lui lançait
une pyramide et que si on détruit la
balle devant maîtrise homérique avec un
petit délai une petite latence mais le
sommet ceni pas ça parce que je me
considère supérieur je veux dire qu'on
est les derniers arrivés et les premiers
arrivés on en a besoin on peut pas les
éliminer 6ème et élimine bien la
pyramide s'écroule
donc il faut réinventer une économie
industrielle qui soit respectueuse de
cela c'est ce que nous essayons c'est en
nous appuyant la voir sur une
expérimentation nous faisons à seine
saint denis depuis maintenant quatre ans
dans différents domaines
nous avons eu des résultats vraiment
tout à fait on encourage un au monde dit
nous sommes d'ailleurs je tiens à vous
préciser soutenue essentiellement par le
monde industriel et bancaire une banque
publique laquelle dépôts et
consignations deux banques privées qui
sont créés des mineurs et la sûreté
générale est un argument de l'entreprise
privée comme danone dassault systèmes
orange etc des fondations la fondation
de france la fondation afnic et nous
avons développé toute une dynamique
nouvelle qui extrêmement prometteuse en
développement aussi les nouveaux modèles
économiques fondés sur des nouveaux
modèles de comptabilité et nous essayons
d'intégrer y compris les nouvelles
normes comptables prescrite par l'union
européenne donc nous
travailler de manière très
professionnelle et de manière à
intéresser y compris le big business
comme on dit parfois pourquoi parce que
le big business est certaine ce lien il
ya peut-être un nouveau business acer
voilà que faire des avions pour moins de
co2 et tout ça nous nous disons aussi
vraiment voulais faire ça il faut faire
une intégration toutes ces questions à
l'échelle de la de la biosphère et ça
suppose de changer les règles de
comptabilité pour faire ces changements
vrai de comptabilité d'une manière qui
soit vraiment sérieuse il faut beaucoup
beaucoup expérimenté et cette
expérimentation vous savez l'industrie
automobile s'est développé avec enrique
fort aux états unis mais avant une
méforme et beaucoup d'autres gens qu'on
développe l'usagé de vos billets qui
sont ruinés morgan par exemple alors
qu'ils existent toujours parce que
c'était le fil d'une banque et que là il
a été maintenu en vie par par par
l'activité financière mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'ils sont
toujours expérimentés avant que le
modèle fordiste par exemple et été
transformés véritablement nouveau modèle
macroéconomique il dit s'est écoulé 30
ans entre les premières idées de haine
des formes en 1908 et le tournant de 25
en 25 ans le tournant de ce qu'on
appelait le new deal rose ld lines donc
il faut il faut expérimenter maintenant
aller le plus vite possible parce qu'il
ya extrême urgence et le giec qui le dit
95% du les avis scientifiques sur le
sujet des climats et nous pensons que
pour cela et bien faut créer une
dynamique qui va être capable d'inventer
une nouvelle économie
à travers ces processus
d'expérimentation merci bernard stiegler
je rappelle que bifurquer qui est un
livre collectif vient de paraître aux
liens qui libèrent on se retrouve juste
après une pause avec deux bergers qui
sort un nouvel album
[Musique]
rudd biogée bonjour vous sortez un
nouvel album intitulé environ pourquoi
ce titre qu'elle est sa signification
alors c'est un titre qui s'est imposé en
fait c'est c'est mon fils qui par
ailleurs est responsable de tout
l'artwork de l'album qui va qui m'a
suggéré ce titre parce que j'étais
vraiment en rap je n'arrivais pas à
trouver cet album qui est un peu
particulier qui qui est assez qui est
délibérément disparates éclectique qui
va dans plein de directions différentes
et qui en même temps été fabriqué
entièrement dans ce studio que j'ai dans
un vallon d'alsace là et au fond ça
c'est à poser oui là il a tout
simplement photos que photographier un
détail d'une carte une vieille carte
peintes à la main comme mon avis frais
de poulet m'avait offert qui avait
trouvé aux puces de clignancourt il sur
cette carte ya les environs de colmar ya
l'endroit de précisément environ studio
et en suisse il a cadré ce mot environ
le le bout de cartes sim à digérer tous
les élans les titres des morceaux à la
place des des banlieues et voilà et puis
alors j'ai découvert après coup et ça
sera évidemment enchanté que environ
peut s'entendre aussi comme un impératif
ça a été un verbe qui signifiait tourner
sur soi même jusqu'à l'extase
l'étourdissement livre ex quo c'est sous
finances lui voilà c'est ça donc il y
avait un verbe en virée qui donne
environ à l'impératif la première
personne du pluriel c'est la pression
vous avez vous-même dedans viré oui oui
c'est exactement ce qui se passe quand
on travaille dans un studio au fond 1 et
celui là particulièrement s'il est
vraiment au castrés comme ça dans un
vallon qui convaincra terre un peu et
oui il ya un aspect matrice com
là on tourne les morceaux où on dit bien
les tournées quoi des espaces quelque
chose c'est à dire que le produit
l'espace temps on voyage ou à quoi on
dérive on est dans une périphérie nation
à partir d'un endroit
et ça ça me paraît convenir tout à fait
ce qui s'est produit voilà très très
simplement et concrètement on a fait ce
disque on regarde tout de suite un
extrait du clip de bleu bac
le morceau qui ouvre l'album un clip
réalisé par votre ami fred poulet
les paroles sont inspirées yam
boisaubert bleus bac
[Musique]
sur l'étal le pack
j'ai vu des chapeaux carapace d'hameçons
s'accrocher
reine des cygnes corps du dragon créent
deux épique
sur l'étal bleus bac j'ai vu le regard
de plans du poulpe maudit culotte
glouton
g
mes yeux vu les jours ça les rues l'an
stridulent est en pleine forme
sur leurs pointes ou des toiles
en tirant la langue j'ai vu les rougets
du rocher tiré à quatre épingles le
reste est amer
j'ai vu simuler la différence et
décamper rentrer la danse
[Musique]
vu la main de garenne sage et le saute
mouton dans devant
en riant
il eût été habité de l'idée tout en
prendront mais avaler créé par les
ostréiculteurs joueur de banjo de
l'étang de thau à leurs plus beaux
souvenirs ou sans abri
applaudie
au rythme
[Musique]
je vous vois
de monsieur voir
[Musique]
elle met les yeux
deux fois
je vous ai vu
deux mesures et des foyers pour un anti
ouf
j'ai vue du chrono des jo
un clip rodolphe budget que vous avez
enregistré juste avant le confinement
pendant le confinement justement vous
avez donné des concerts virtuels devant
votre téléphone
ça fait quoi comme sensation la première
fois c'est très très étrange
et puis j'étais un peu réticent j'avais
pas envie de me donner dans le savez le
c'est devenu une espèce de genre en soi
quoi le le téléphone le morceau joué le
matin en pyjama dans sa cuisine avec un
son pourri et tout ça va je n'avais pas
du tout envie je vais pas pourquoi
j'allais infliger ça les containers quoi
du coup les hits et mais il se trouve
que j'étais dans mon j'avais la grande
chance d'être dans mon studio avec mon
ingénieur du son je me suis précipitée
là bas etc
et du coup je pouvais
soyez leçons et ça c'était important
ouais c'est vrai que la première fois
quand on se retrouve comme ça faire un
concert devant son téléphone c'est assez
étrange et c'est seulement après coup
qu'on découvre que c'est pas que si
virtuelle que ça qu'il ya plein de gens
qui étaient là ce rendez-vous et que et
qui en plus ils vous envoient des
messages
les découvre après ils sont commandes
fervent quoi ils envoient des coeurs et
des trucs c'est à dire que là on partage
quelque chose donc on n'est pas dans la
virtualité tant que ça lalala par
exemple nous sommes en direct
donc à partir de là nous sommes ne
sommes pas là dans la virtualité on est
dans quelque chose qui se rapproche
voilà du temps réel du concert du coup
quand je lui ai fait une deuxième fois
on m'a proposé c'est le centre pompidou
de metz qui a eu voilà cette idée de
faire la nouvelle directrice
c'est formidable on ferme concernant
plus sonne comme une performance d'art
contemporain est en réalité il y avait
du public
ces terres publiques
un peu de hasard c'était le premier jour
de déconfinement donc les gens qui
disaient que les courses et tout ça est
qui qui s'approchait qui était intrigué
je jouais dans dans l'entrée du musée et
il y avait des pompiers qui les tenait à
distance
mais voilà je n'étais plus seule tout à
fait et puis même je dirais ou face et
de cette expérience là ces deux experts
le fonds pourrait amener à réviser un
peu mon jugement là-dessus quoi je
trouve que dès lors qu'il ya un rendez
vous voilà il n'ya dans les dents
oui on est plus dans la virtualité et
vous êtes alsacien comme tomi ungerer
comme alain bashung
le studio dont vous nous parlez est en
alsace
quelle est l'influencé alsace à thélus
sur vos chansons sur votre musique
alors là vraiment aucune j'espère tu
vois est ce que le folklore alsacien
malheureusement et parce qu'il ya de
plus de plus intéressant à la garder
cette région sa plus haute plutôt servi
de repoussoir et très vite évidemment
valable l'âge de 10 ans pas mal comme
pas mal de gens de ma génération secte
et tout d'un coup sec et le rock venu
d'ailleurs aux bâches ou nuls en parle
aussi le décor dit c'était ces radios
ces fameuses radio des bases américaines
en allemagne qui nous amenait du très
bon rock'n'roll qui nous permettait
justement d'échapper à cette espèce de
de folklore absolument sinistre dit le
folklore alsacien ce qui la 2g rien pour
des fois que l'on va rencontrer jeu je
travaille pas d'emplois que comment
pendant qu erik marchand on n'est pas un
chanteur breton qui travaillez-vous
travail lui-même régler les musiciens
roumains qui quelquefois d'ailleurs je
joue les mêmes thèmes que les que les
fanfares alsacienne mais l'énorme
différence est que les roumains joue ça
à partir d'une tradition orale
transmission orale et du joug de façon
vivante alors que en alsace on le joue
depuis les partitions les allemands ont
fixé c'est là les allemands qui ont
voulu fixer une fois que leur alsaciens
ils ont figé quoi et l'ont tué
donc l'alsace le bruit attendez je vous
interromps parce que vous avez l'air de
dire du mal des allemands mais dans cet
album vous reprenez un morceau de ta
très très grand groupe de pop allemand
c'est cannes et le morceau ses mains
chaudes ils ont fait du très bon rock
les allemands aussi et bien sûr mais
justement c'est au space et ohb si je
pense qu'ils étaient dans la même
situation encore plus encore c'est là
vous savez bien que l'allemagne produit
n'a pas que leur musique le pire et le
meilleur
celle que
la variété allemande sans doute une des
pires du monde ce qu'on appelle
l'arrière et c'est aussi très
certainement le sait hors d'allemagne
enfin on trouve les mélomanes les plus
incroyables j la musique l'oci la plus
extraordinaire pas seulement la musique
classique ou romantique mais en effet le
rock allemand pour moi était quelque
chose de très important
et d'autant plus qu'il était obligé
d'inventer
après la guerre les allemands les jeunes
allemands n'avaient pas leur disposition
comme les anglais je dirais un folklore
digne et les beatles vont aller les
harmonies vocales c'est finalement ça on
voit bien que ça vient de quelque chose
assez profond or nos terres dans la
tradition alors que les allemands il a
le plus tradition c'était la table rase
du réinventer et les anglais quand ils
ont besoin de ce juste en de se
ressourcer d'aller comment dire aller
chercher quelque chose de plus radical
je pense à bowie brian eno ils sont
allés ou en allemagne
ils sont allés voir ces gens ils sont
allés voir d'un oeil sur les écoutes et
kraftwerk sur les voir codip langue
c'est ces gens qui à berlin fabriquer un
roc
je dirais plus oui plus radicale plus
donc moins pop plus rapide plus intense
plus dense qui à moi et moi de plus en
plus à jouer sur scène c'est ce nouvel
album en deux branches et il ya une
chanson que vous interpréter en duo avec
christophe qui nous a malheureusement
quittés pendant le confinement
cette chanson c'est un classique de
votre groupe kat onoma et s'intitule la
chambre ou à vous retrouver avec
christophe au trianon en 2010 est
justement en train de l'interpréter ça
avait été filmée par par yvan chirac à
l'époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ma chambre creux que rire une pas
poutine 30 guérir
dans le thé les landes deux chiens
silence
[Musique]
et après le débat pour comme dit
que
fonçant les sourcils rigueur
c'est bizarre
la mâche ans on veut crier au 30 janvier
le terril ans de chant
un silence
[Musique]
et après le débat qu'on 10 15 noeuds
sans me soucier
boudet
ça
[Musique]
aurier comédie
une journée pour vous servir d' a connu
parapluies ici
[Musique]
on
dans la chambre c'est une chanson que
christophe avait beaucoup interprété je
me suis je le connaissais bien il m'en
avait parlé de cette chanson je crois
qu'il était vraiment amoureux de cette
chanson oui c'est vrai la première fois
qu'on avait quand même qu'on s'est
vraiment rencontré tadié re quand vous
savez savez bien comment ça se passe à
il fallait passer la nuit quoi est en
effet très vite parler de cette chanson
il appelait pas la chambre il appelait
la petite pomme par l'autre de kat onoma
qui est un groupe qui a duré plus de
vingt ans pourquoi y avez vous mis fin
parce qu'au fond entre un album comme
celui qui vient de sortir et les album
de kat onoma je trouve qu'à pas une
telle différence
y a pas de rupture c'est toujours des
levures g oui c'est vrai pourquoi oui et
puis en effet l'album se clôt avec cette
version de la chambre avec christophe
les et philippe poirier de kat onoma qui
est venu mettre une guitare on a on a
sorti récemment avec philippins un
disque qui s'appelle play kat onoma on
rejoue des morceaux de notre histoire
les années après donc pour moi ça le
sens du fait qu'à thomas pourrait tout à
fait continuer aujourd'hui sauf que
quand même bix le prophétise du groupe
et est décédé ce qui est interdit
voilà une vraie formation et puis et
puis quand même et ce qui s'est passé
vers 2003 quoi sais c'est que moi j'ai
multiplié les projets le projet solo ou
en collaboration quatre jours marester
mon espèce de port d'attaché je
l'adorais toujours revenir mais mais
certainement qu'une quand même un
certain dissymétrie s'est installée
entre nous voilà des jeux pour moi ce
groupe et d'une certaine façon est
toujours présent je rejoue les morceaux
de kat onoma volontiers il et je suis
ravi de constater qu'à des jeux grâce à
ses nageoires des jeunes gens le va'a
temps où il ya de me parler de ce groupe
donc on entreprend d'ailleurs de va
essayer de rééditer de manière complète
l'ensemble
c'est un groupe qui avait la réputation
d'être élitiste intellectuelle pour ceux
qui ne les met pas vous même vous avez
été professeur de philo est ce que est
ce que véritablement pour vous c'était
un intellectuel kat onoma vous pouvez
facilement imaginer ce que je pense de
sa devoir à la fois à la fois je suis
partagé puisque j'ai envie là bien sûr
j'étais prof de philo mais d'abord j'ai
fait du rock bien avant de faire de la
philo j'ai jamais considéré que ni que
la philo et est une affaire purement
intellectuel et ni queue ni que
évidemment la musique du groupe
et quoi que ce soit de d'élitiste enfin
absolument pas quoi et je trouve que
j'étais toujours à ses grains mais
comment dire déçu et dépité dû constater
que si ce reproche parce que c'était
vraiment un reproche comme si on était
presque in situ presque une insulte quoi
des fous et souvent qui émanait de gens
qui qu'ils étaient eux-mêmes quand même
d'anciens profs ou des écrivains jeu
moins raté vos réussi mais c'est très
étrange ces reproches qu'on l'a jamais
fait à john key à koufra trucs sur ce
qu'ils souhaitent shakespeare pas le
traité l'intello mais on voit bien avec
les paroles de myriam boisaubert qu'on
écoutait tout à l'heure dans le camp
bleu rock
vous avez gardé ce côté rock littéraire
qui pour moi est un truc très français
on le voit chez feu chatterton
aujourd'hui ils ont des textes
qui sonne très littéraire et s'est
volontairement littéraire comme vous
avez osé le faire vous aussi il ya
trente ans maintenant
oui je suis content de constater que
c'est un petit peu moins mal vu
aujourd'hui et est que même voilà c'est
quelqu'un comme bertrand voilà est-ce
que c'est littéraire du littéraire c'est
juste que c'est super bien écrit voilà
c'est ça on va écouter un extrait des
danses anglaise un autre morceau qui
figurent sur ce nouvel album
les danses anglaise s'installe il est là
il va distance qui a été réalisé par
fred poulet on vous regarde et on vous
écoute
[Musique]
il
connaissez vous les dents ch
[Musique]
ce sont denses
qui se déhanche
[Musique]
quiconque
connaissez-vous les danseuses anglais
ce sont de danse qui se danse comme
angle droit
il faut être trois mais la musique dans
rayonnait bassam un souk où se cachent à
côté du visage avec sa main madeleine
passe sa main sous son coude se cache
l'autre côté du visage avec sam a retiré
sa main sous en cours retire sa main
comme si son coude se cacher le visage
l'excès
avec la main car l'autre cet égard et
avec la pince
car l'autre s'est effacée
[Musique]
sans main et visages pas dessus bras
dessous
pas de l'air cas de l'amo
connaissez-vous les temps sont en
anglais
plon
à de la taça main tout son cours ce sont
des danses
que ce dense
120 divisa bras dessus dessous
[Musique]
rodolphe burj et j'ai l'impression que
vous avez passé toute votre carrière à
lutter contre l'industrie musicale pour
pour défendre votre indépendance
artistique quand on voit en fait tout ce
qui s'est passé autour du confinement et
quand on vous écoute et qu'on regarde
les clips les concerts virtuels que vous
avez pu donner enfin même s'il n'était
pas si virtuelle que ça le studio qu'on
voyait là qui est votre studio aussi
qu'au fond aujourd'hui un artiste peut
complètement se passer de l'industrie du
disque est la fois pour pour enregistrer
pour ses concerts pour ses tournées qui
pourrait même presque resté chez lui et
faire carrière
ouais faut pas exagérer 1
je sais pas j'ai refait récemment un
entretien de de mano solo basse je me
souvenais de mano solo
à ce propos il avait il a justement
produit un album à démontrer à quel
point c'était notre production et il ne
croyez pas que c'est si facile et c'est
juste que les je pense que les relations
se modifie les rapports de force ne sont
plus les mêmes
certainement c'est que c'est pas du tout
quand qu'on peut tout faire tout seul ça
c'est quand même à l'heure enfin il ya
des exemples en effet voilà
mais c'est surtout dans un domaine c'est
ce qu'on appelle musique dans les
maisons d'ici dans une catégorie pour ça
c'est la musique qui tout d'un coup elle
explose sur internet il ya un titre
il fait des millions de 10 millions de
clics et voilà et après les maisons de
disques avons signé l'artiste mais après
qu'est ce que ça donne en live
qu'est ce que ça donne dans la durée ça
c'est une autre question donc il ya des
phénomènes comme ça des choses qui
éclosent d'elle-même sur internet mais
c'est pas possible de construire une
vraie voilà le vrai chemin musical
uniquement comme ça et donc on a besoin
d'un partenaire simplement ses
partenaires voilà le leur
c'est vrai que ça vous avez raison j'ai
été en lutte tout le temps tout le temps
avec les professionnels de la profession
pas comme d'ilona il travaille avec des
modèles qui me correspondait absolument
pas et j'ai été obligé de demander tout
le temps les dérogations
je vais faire un disque avec olivier
cadiot mon ami l'écrivain sur une
peuplade welz yeux dans les montagnes
alsacienne il dit c'est mon rêve de
faire l'artiste
c'était vraiment ça tout le temps tout
en fait nous indices tranquille où tous
les deux ans suivie de sa tournée soit
notre nouveau bachelot et donc et à la
vertu voyez alain qui lui était très
pâle pas jaloux du tout aimé bendit a de
la chance d'être indépendant et on a
fait des choses en même temps alain
bashung hinanui tient attendu si
longtemps le succès parce qu'il avait
commencée au tout début des années à la
fin des années 60 un il a attendu 14 ans
je crois avoir vraiment que ça ça
décolle est il nécessaire de faire des
disques qui normalement devait renverser
complètement le courrier est annulé le
résultat du disque précédent
il a passé son temps à annuler les
succès qu'il venait d'avoir ça non mais
là lui voilà c'est un parcours
exemplaire à leur arrivée et toujours
ami en effet toujours dans une espèce de
négociations complexes avec la pression
les indices mais bon c'est vrai que van
bla maintenant ce que je peux dire en
tout cas c'est que j'ai là je je
considère que j'ai beaucoup de chance
c'est à dire de de pouvoir garder
l'initiative par exemple dans le
confinement voilà je n'étais pas
complètement condamné à rester dans ma
cuisine chanter du brassens
j'ai pu aller dans mon studio chez un
studio dans lequel je produis des choses
et j'ai entendu sur un public qui me
suit il est bon je travaille énormément
mais avec aussi aussi parce que je
profite je dirais en fin de set de cette
indépendance chèrement gagnée quand même
vous serez le 13 décembre à l'olympia de
l'année prochaine de l'année prochaine
c'est vrai et c'est 2021
oui il y aura des dates avant avant ça
on peut pas être on peut être sûr de
rien en fait français merci ronald
berger je rappelle que l'album
s'intitule environ et puis bah c'est la
dernière émission de la saison il faut
bien le dire
donc on l'a passée ensemble
virtuellement mais en fait quand même en
direct en vivent
donc on se retrouve à la rentrée mais il
y aura évidemment des extraits des
émissions pendant tout l'été je vous
souhaite un très bon été merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]